we are back Oprah and Tana hotsie-totsie
told us before we went on I hate long
introduction to say it's John Haase
here's a book that he wrote newest book
club selection there it is it's a first
in her partnership with Apple that's a
big deal the novel tells the story of a
young boys we mentioned born into
bondage on a plantation and the
mysterious power that he discovers I
think the Apple partnership is
interesting because I think you're gonna
have more readers I that that was my
whole goal is to partner with Apple and
have a wide bandwidth so that we can
create a community of readers around the
world and I am most excited for people
all over the world to start reading this
and then go to add Oprah's Book Club
which is my new Instagram for books and
just have a discussion about cuz when
you start reading it you're gonna want
to talk to somebody yeah Gail Gail Gail
called me the other day and she was like
I won't say web page but she's like what
is gonna happen in Georgia I don't want
to keep I'm afraid to turn the page
what's gonna happen I go you know I'm
not gonna do my mom stop reading at that
part for a while cuz it could have gone
one of two ways and I was like you know
let's talk about your mom for a second
because you told me that this really
started as not a love letter but it was
like a love story yeah you know my mom
she um she was a she is a very very
diverse you know reader but you know she
my mom so I hope I'm not embarrassing
she loves romance novels embarrassing I
don't know people make assumptions I
don't think it's embarrassing like I
read comic books I don't not like I'm
standing on I yeah people make
assumptions anyway my mom loves romance
novels and you know I when I was like I
don't know young like 19 20 you know I
said all right one day I'm gonna write
you a romance and then when I gave her
the advanced version I said here it is
[ __ ] you guys this is romance boy she
got it eventually she was like yeah it
is but early on maybe you don't quite
it's not clear you know so didn't you
see those a love story I saw it yes I
saw it well first of all I was
enthralled I was devastated
felt hope I felt gratitude I feel joy I
mean it's the range of emotions that's
why I think it has everything that a
novel
what's that I'm actually on my second
read now because the first read I was
just reading as I see if I was gonna
choose it and then the second read I
actually am sort of spoon-feeding every
word to myself you are a magnificent
right thank you and I you know what when
I went the other day I was reading I was
thinking gosh I wish Tony was alive to
actually to read this book she would be
so proud so who's gonna give it to our
reluctant political commentator I'm
gonna take it Anthony
well alright here we go I'll take it I
really was hoping some would jump where
there was talk about you running in 2020
you're not running in 2020 do you said
that many times yeah you were great not
running Oh Mike when I'm watching the
debates I was actually also asked to be
to moderate to moderate one of the
debates and I didn't even want to do
that and when I thought I should a baton
yeah it was like he should I'm watching
the debates I'm like so happy I'm not in
any other did you how did you did you
seriously consider I didn't I never did
never know because it's the kind of
thing I think you feel in your your gut
your soul no you know if that is the
thing you're supposed to do in real life
can't explain the sound Oprah said that
Jesus would have to call her in order
for her to do it and I told her Jesus
called me what should I say but you also
have a very interesting take you'd said
if you were running you would only focus
on what you would do for the country
yeah I think opposed to all the negative
actually I think a lot of the candidates
make the biggest mistake mistakes and
certainly this happened in the previous
election you know there is a there's a
law natural law that says what you give
your attention to expands so you should
not talk about the other die because you
only empower your opponents when you
talk about them you should talk about
what you are going to do and as little
as possible not discuss what the other
guys are moving for it John Ahoskie any
thoughts
um I'm sorry I didn't come we're gonna
get cut off here thank you
we'll be right back